good back-to-back miss layups canter
down low and finishes
he is so good around the basket the lead
back up to eight
the ranch jumper got it and you could
just look at his body language doubling
up the Warriors 46 to 20 of plus 26
Livingston wings falling away and one
guard in the league that is very best in
the paint good content by Roberson it's
road trip that ends here tonight
Thompson pull-up jumper got it and when
the Warriors throw the ball in the post
for some wide open high arcing three
misses similar the rebound putback mrs.
canter tips it up and in
reporter shortly right back out to
Iguodala fast inside Barnes with the
plush and at 40 in the first meeting
between the two he's got 32 so far Green
with the deflection finds its way to
Singler
[Applause]
Loran finds atoms atoms black pipe dream
among three what a rejection from green
times this happen we seen draymond Green
come over and protect the rim that's a
big-time play not on my watch that's a
big time foul what are you look at it he
sits out and that's a big time play the
games going Miami they were down in the
fourth quarter had to come back and win
the Warriors Westbrook drives and
finishes tough shot
let's see a beautiful offensive play the
thing that interests me though each and
every night green inside the Thompson
Thompson gets that one to go so now with
21
[Music]
hurry to the basket layup is good grant
to work off of that Curry from downtown
that's good
bearing from way downtown that's a
four-point game
this is great defense Adams is there the
contest is death curry knocks down the
shot clap your hands give them credit
but Trust as a game plan is secure with
multiple timeouts neither has a foul to
give
curry from downtown that's a 10
Stephon curry it's a two-point game with
a minute and a half to play
they Thompson and Westbrook expecting a
switch backs up just a little bit beyond
it Durant back out Westbrook Westbrook
attacks to Ibaka 2 pointer knocks it in
curry out to Thompson 3-pointer
one-point game Durant on the drive
Ibaka back out Durant for three
Thompson drives to the hoop lays it in
quickly still 11.8 remaining save it and
he does a hefty igudala big Atala puts
it up no whistle on the foul a foul is
called
that is too much free throws right there
from the veteran and poor some
miscommunications inside Durant puts it
up over time we get five more minutes of
this
good defense by draymond Green a contest
makeable shot gotta live with
[Music]
now with two timeouts in 120 let's go
then one Adams end to read in the
pick-and-roll action Westbrook no help
turns the corner gets the contact and
the baskets and Steven Adams started
overtime got the tip and 16 rebounds for
Serge Ibaka
[Applause]
Durant finds Ibaka little [ __ ] but
greens made some huge defensive plays
curry for three
now sit ten three-pointers back-to-back
games with ten threes and he ties his
NBA record for most threes in a season
and what coach is right they come out
allow Robinson to not be defended 8
o'clock of finishes at the other end
curry another three pitch go the courier
up ssin continues the tie game I have
the single game record Roberson
flashlight three Robinson gets it back
and banks it in
[Applause]
Kobe Bryant and Daniel Marsh will have
the record see baka jump hook bounces
around and rolls in and the lead is four
timeout Golden State
punter in and out off the mark rebound
Green Green finds Thompson history
pointer that's good
back to one Russell Western Westbrook
drives pass inside Robertson Robertson's
lamp it's good sight of your
responsibility green backdoor Thompson
reverse layup banks it in and a foul
[ __ ] up sit down hit in the head and
he can tie the game of the free throw
line let's bring on the drive falling
away won't go rebound taken by Iguodala
they do have a timeout decide not to use
it curry way downtown with six tension
second remaining
that's about 35 feet out well beyond the
28 foot mark and now it's six tenths of
a second remaining it's a three point
lead
obviously Oklahoma City has to go for a
three Westbrook gets up a good luck
won't go in Golden State his stark wind
continues we'll a signature friend here
in OKC